Welcome everybody, Jason Rosen here, once again with Dr. Kevin Connors to go through
the next part of our series on the gut.
We are titling this presentation, gut 201.
We are going to get into some really cool information about the mechanisms of gut healing
inflammation, what happens as the gut slowly deteriorates, some of the genetic aspects
of that, and without further ado, Dr. Kevin, why don't you take us
and as you got a little more intro before we pop to the first slide.
Nope, let's get cooking.
All right, let's get cooking.
Let's get digesting.
Let's get digesting, yeah.
All right, well this slide tells a lot pictures worth a thousand words, right?
So normally you have these little
villi in your gut to everybody knows the anatomy.
It comes from embryonic cell line of your epithelial cells.
That's important as we look at your genetics.
And you could probably say that every disease begins in the gut pretty much
not every disease, but good portion of them, right?
Fast majority.
And you can see why, like you said, with this slide right here.
Yeah, so that's what you really, you deal with anything.
I have all my cancer patients watch a video that I created.
I can't remember the title of it, but it talks about gut health.
And it's because everybody, I got cancer.
It's got colon cancer, it's lung cancer, or brain cancer, or something.
Why would I have to deal with the gut?
So I actually created a video explaining why you have to deal with the gut.
Because we use sun spectrum as you know, Jason, literally on 99.9% of our patients.
So it's just a must.
If you don't address the gut, I always tell people, you know, inflammation of the gut
is going to equal inflammation everywhere else in the body.
So if you don't control that inflammation, then it's a more difficult disease,
or whatever disease you're dealing with, it's going to be more difficult to deal with.
So, that's it. We're trying to cover here.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, this is just, yeah, like you said, it's just a really great video just to watch.
How well we were really created, and how bad we can,
well, actually just how resilient our bodies are, how much they actually put up with before
they're finally just like enough is enough, you know.
Before things break down, yep.
All right, should we pop to the next slide then?
Yes, sir.
All right, there we go.
Okay, so there's different ways to measure gut function.
This is a slide just taken from a picture of Genova's test, a stool sample test.
They're 2,200 or 2,205.
I can remember which test this is from.
Quite honestly, I don't do this test that much.
Jason, because I just come from the assumption we got to work on the gut.
And everybody's going to be messed up.
There's going to be very few sick people that walk in my office that don't have gut dysfunction.
And then again, the argument is that they think they don't, because their tummy doesn't hurt.
Or they have bubble lids every day.
And I've had people come in and I'm sure other doctors on listening to this have had people come in
and you say, do you have regular bubble lids?
They say, oh, yes, I have every three days, you know.
Their skin is white, you know.
Well, insane, they're doctors.
That's how long you know that that is normal.
Right, exactly.
So I don't run this test very often, but this is a good thing for people at different, you know,
I see mainly cancer and live patients that they'll just do anything.
I tell them to do better what so I don't have to run some of these other labs to prove it to them.
But I suggest, I suggest highly if you're running a car practice or you're trying to get it
in a functional medicine that you, you learn how to use these labs.
But you know, if I have some really nice videos explaining their labs, I know other labs have
videos explaining their labs too. And this could help you put some, you know, teeth into
their treatment plan and get them to do the next things that you want them to do.
So I think there's benefit to this.
That's the, yeah, I think that's the whole point of labs.
We already know what we need to work on, but it's, the patient needs to see it.
I've heard good things about GI map testing, but yeah, this is a good slide too,
because I'm sure a lot of the docs out there that are, you know, getting into this,
they've read grain brain and brain maker by Pearl Mudder.
And, you know, one of the things he hits hard on, especially in brain makers for micutees,
and how that just causes all kinds of different issues in just about any neurological,
you know, problem out there. And you know, this is a, it's a nice test that they, they run that
there. And then also buterate, he hits hard on buterate and how important buterate is.
And I know that's another reason, you know, I love the sun spectrum is the sun fiber.
And there's just an amazing source for, for buterate.
Yeah, it's like really a key piece.
And then with for micutees, I know we like the C3 reduct is a really good thing to bring that down.
I know green tea works really well for that as well. Do you have any other aces you use for
for micutees? Well, look at, you use the products to help bring that down.
enzymes are really important in my book for that too. So because really, you know, we're looking at
this test here is really looking at intestinal function. But where does that come from, that comes
from stomach. So using digestive aids that begin higher up in the stomach that is digestive enzymes
for the duodenum and HCl for the stomach is important as well. So that's usually where it begins.
Yeah, I think like when an old mentor of mine just goes like hydrochloric acid is one of his favorite
supplements. And he wrote some really interesting papers on just like you could trace back just about
like any low rate infection to a lack of hydrochloric acid. And then you hear so many people out there say,
oh, well, I make enough HCl. I don't need to supplement HCl. And like really do you really think
you're eating the food that you're originally designed to eat and you're not demanding like 50 times
more hydrochloric acid reserves than you, you know, by the time you're 30, then you're probably designed
to use by the time you're 80. It's just kind of interesting. Well, that's exactly right. I mean,
no, really is people say they think that they're because they have a reflux that they have too much,
you know, stomach acid, which is actually the opposite of that. And the most commonly prescribed
it utilized medication today is a mephrasol and the other acid-loweried medication, even if a person
is on, you know, just some over the counter-rollates. That's just the worst they a person could take.
People don't make enough HCl because they have damaged stomach lighting from foods and other chemicals
that they're adjusting, flavorings, coloring, additives, all this stuff. And they have MTHFR and other
defects on their folate pathway. And the B vitamins are essential for the production of HCl.
And I get a lot in the cancer circles. Everybody's trying to alkalize themselves. So they're
purchasing these alkalized water units. All right. And my comment is, uh, let's think about this
a little bit. Right. Where that you want to alkalize the tissue, that's fantastic. So it's
drinking alkalized water, going to alkalize the tissue. So let's just go back and think of physiology.
101, your stomach acid, the alkalinity of your stomach should be about
1.5 to 3.5 pH. You're going to drink an alkalized water. 12.08, you know, water and stuff like that.
Right. And think that that's going to alkalize the tissue. I mean, you're just, you're missing
physiology. 101 here. So you drink lemon water. Is lemon water alkalizing or acidifying to the tissue?
Well, it's alkalizing. Well, stick a pH strip of the lemon water. It's acidic. You know,
it's not whether the thing that you're drinking is acidic or alkalite. It's whether you're
thinking the thing that you're drinking or eating is alkalizing to the tissues. So it's not the pH
of the substance. No, it's a great point. Like anyone can just start, you know, swallowing like
teaspoon the baking soda every day and they could get their urine pH up, you know. Sure,
you could just take a bunch of minerals and you get your urine pH up, but that doesn't mean your tissue
pH is up. Absolutely not. You're going to spill calcium in the urine. You're going to increase the
pH of the urine that people have this fallacy of, oh, I've alkalized my tissue. Really, you got
alkalized urine. Right. Yeah. So if you had alkalized tissue, you wouldn't have cancer or all these other
right issues. And it's just it's just not understanding the physiology. I mean, a person with cancer has
acidity around that cancer because the cancer is highly metabolic because it's because it's
replicating. That's what cancer is. So you got all this rapid replication. It's highly metabolic.
You got all this waste that's billied up around the cancer. That is what is acidic. The cancer is
acidified. That is really the warburg effect, the acidification of the tissue by the cancer.
And the only way to alkalize it is by eating a good diet, eating raw foods. It isn't drinking something
that's alkaline. Yep. So we're way off subject. But it isn't off subject to the sense that it is
it's you're dealing with the gut and one of the first things that you want to if only a person could
take a U.S. enzyme product that is one of my favorite is the HClzyme. All they did is give their
patients that if you want to run a run a straight car practice office, well, all you did is tell
everybody to go on HClzyme and take one with every meal. You could save a person's life. You don't
call people's lives you're saving. So yeah, I totally agree. And that's I know another thing what you
and I love so much about enzymes is they have such a broad reaching effect, especially when you
take them properly in a like a maintenance type basis. So all right. Should we roll on here? All right.
Okay. Food sensitivities. So you're just trying to identify sources of inflammation, right? So
one source of inflammation is what we talked about. You know what I would have HCl you're not making
enough HCl. You're getting food that's going into the gut that's not properly digested.
And if you have a damaged gut epithelial wall like in the first slide that we showed where the
visual there picture that damaged epithelial wall is what's called leaky gut, right? So you have
space between the cells that is greater than what it should be. Therefore things are getting
across the gut border that shouldn't get across the gut border. So proteins that should get broken
down into amino acids before they go across the gut border are going across the gut border in larger
size molecules called peptides. So larger than one single amino acid is two which would be a
dipeptide greater than that is a peptide. And if you got things crossing that are larger than at least
the dipeptide size then your immune system is going to go what the heck is that? Yeah. And it's a
foreign substance. We got to kill it. And last I checked the peptides don't die. So the immune system
is constantly firing against that and could create antibodies against that. And now you have antibodies
against foods that are good for you. Yep. And at every time you
adjust something that you have an antibody against you're going to fire an immune system
reaction and you're going to fire what's called a TH1 reaction which is inflammatory which is
going to cause inflammation which is going to further damage the gut and everywhere else in the body.
Yep, brain, the thyroid, you know, those are the some of the biggies. And another so
oh, sorry, go ahead. Go ahead. Yeah, I was just going to say just kind of going back to, you know,
healing the gut. Yes, we want to seal the gut. We want to get the people off the foods that they're
firing these you know, hyper reactions against. But then the proteins are still there. So it's another
thing, you know, these that's where systemic enzymes can come in and be just the real gods and a lot
of patients because those proteins can then be broken down by the enzymes and you know, another
just great reason they are so good for, you know, bringing down inflammation. Right. So like this
test that you see out here is the Syrex test. I personally think that's the best test for testing for
foods. But it's not cheap. And most people's insurance isn't going to pay for it. So if you're,
if you have a patient on a budget, just put them on more enzymes because just like you said, Jason,
okay, it is the peptides that you that you are reacting to. So remember what a what a
a protein is, a long shade of amino acids in a certain sequence that make it that protein. So
and as you're your enzymes break that apart. So if you could think of it as a long shade of a
pearl necklace. So you got these all these pearls in this chain. If you're reacting to certain
legs of that pearl chain certain peptides, if you gave the person a more enzymes to consume when they
eat, they will break those down. They have a greater chance of breaking them down into amino acids
that won't react. Yep, absolutely. You have a greater chance of decreasing that person's
immune response, decreasing that person's inflammation of the gut with enzymes period. So that's
again, why we love them. So I mean, when you look back in societies, I mean, if you really think about
the first supplement made it was enzymes and probiotics because people have been fermenting,
you know, you know, all these things from K-Fear to Kim Chi, you know, every society has their
little probiotic that they an enzyme player that they've been making since, you know, the dawn of time
and they were using it as basically a supplement to get more enzymes and more probiotics.
Oh, absolutely. I saw a really cool story of the history channel a while back that I share with
a lot of my patients. It was this picture, this kind of story of the black plague and they
shared these beautiful graphics of how the black plague spread across Europe and started to spread
across Asia and it literally went around Korea and they had to figure out why do we have zero
reference of anybody dying of the black plague in Korea. So they went back and did a study and they
found out at that time, the Koreans ate Kim Chi with every meal. Yep. So they were taking enzymes
eating Kim Chi with every meal. At that time, they stored their Kim Chi in a hole in the ground. So
could you imagine it had way more enzymes than it does even today? Right. So that was the only
difference. So they said, well, the Germans ate fermented sauerkraut, but they didn't eat it every
meal. They had that as a meal. It wasn't, you know, a side dish with every meal. So that was the
difference. And it's like, okay, it's a person that they need enzymes. Yeah, exactly. Just because
you make them doesn't mean you make enough and like there's a adaptive law of secretion which was
proven in a study I think in like the 70s that just says that the body reveres its enzymes so much.
It won't spare one extra one unless it absolutely, you know, needs to. So if you can
Well, that's what we talk about the DNA. I mean, it's your DNA that has to make enzymes, right? Right.
That's the whole story of life is good. Yes. We can get really off top if we go much more there,
but we'll stick to the script here and talk about, yeah, some more of these foods and
these beautiful genetically modified foods. So just again, look at try to identify sources
at your patient of inflammation. So you got food sources, you got food sources because if exogenous
chemicals, pesticides, poisons, GMOs. Yeah. So you have to address all these things. And again,
you know, by saying that I say to all my patients is that hey, I'm not expected you to become a guru,
but you can make some choices when you go to the grocery store, you know, you have a choice between
two different tomatoes to buy which one you're going to buy just make the better choice.
So it's it's about getting a person to start thinking about what they're putting to their mouth.
Yeah. And this is this is a really great slide. It just kind of a lot of people think just by going
organic, they're guaranteed not to be GMO. And that's just so not true. And then with the GMO salmon
here is another nice slide. The FDA has recently approved that. So that's going to be coming. So
I'm sure most restaurants will be switching to that. Oh, yeah. Cross savings and, you know,
oil. It's another, another big one. I didn't know this about papaya. So that's interesting.
And we all know that soy, like, I don't care how organic that is. There's the chance of that not
being cross contaminated. It's like almost zero. Yeah, that's the other thing too. It's cross
contamination. It's such it's just scary. We are destroyed our food supply. Yes, we are.
Hopefully we'll wake up soon. Yes, exactly. Okay. Next slide. Okay, so this just goes into kind of
what that one lab from Jinova talked about is this dysbiosis that we have at our gut
chronic infections that we could have our got parasites that we could have in our gut
heavy mental toxicity. There's just a lot of different things that, you know, depended on how deep
you want to go with a person. So, you know, I know we got doctors that listen to this that,
you know, really are into this and try to get as deep as possible with their patients and others
that are, you know, practicing, you know, you know, kind of newbies at functional medicine.
And so we want to kind of hit all those those pieces. But, uh, again,
ruddy those labs could be your best benefit for some of this stuff. Yeah, if you're starting out
and you just hands down, you got to, you got to, and just for yourself too, so you can start to see
the changes yourself and start to, you know, get more confidence in, you know, what you're
suggesting for your patients. But yeah, if you look at all these things that cause gut dysbiosis,
I mean, almost every single one of those on there rely on, you know, one of the two things and
that's a protein to hide from the immune system from the macrophage and, you know, LPS biofilm
to hide from the immune system. And that's just another nice thing about enzymes. They can help,
you know, release those proteins and so the immune system's like, oh, while out there you are,
or that biofilm, where they can do all this crazy things like quorum sensing and some of the,
you know, really tough infections, you got to break those things open just to give the immune
system a fighting, a fighting chance and put the good guys back in and balance the scale.
All right, next slide. This gives you a nice picture of everything we're talking about.
And one of the things that we tend to forget about as natural practitioners is a person's medications.
Oh yeah, for sure. Oh my goodness. You know, it's like, maybe it's just me, but it's like,
I feel like half of my patients, all I'm doing is trying to fix what the medical profession
screwed up. Right. It's like, okay, you know, I've got to a point where a case review of a person's
on a lot of meds, you know, if they're not a cancer patient, I won't even accept them as a patient
because it's just, okay, all I'm doing, all of your symptoms, if you're just Google all the
drugs you're on, they're the side effects. And I'm not going to sit here and try to fix those and
have you get mad at me because you won't get off the drug and you still have all these side effects. So
it's the person has to have, you know, at least a footed the gameplay in here of wanting to get
better, to get off these beds. And again, one of the worst ones are the acid reducers. And that's
what most people are on. Yeah, it's just like, you got to get off that, dude, or you're not going to get
better. Yeah, I mean, I thought I doubt. I know, you know, a lot of practitioners that, you know,
will do like, um, chinesiology just so they can balance out their protocol with the patient's
medications in there because it totally changes the way that what you're doing will work with the
patient. So it's just another nice thing to use. But yeah, it, it is really important to understand
the medications your patients are on their side effects and, you know, how to balance out your
protocol with the medications and try to work as best as you can to, you know, get those things,
get to patient to a state where they don't need them anymore. That's right.
Right. Okay, some genetics. Okay, so there's, there's multiple pieces to the, if you're not
into genetics, it's, this is a, this is a key component of if you really want to dive into this,
this is important to look at. So we talked a little bit about fermented foods, but this, the top
picture of this is the ABP1 gene that breaks down histamine. This makes the DAO enzyme in your gut
to break down histamine, though this particular person does not have any defects on that gene.
So I would instruct this person to use fermented foods as a source of enzymes and probiotics.
Yep. So fermented foods, of course, are a fantastic natural source of, of probiotics.
However, if a person had, you know, a two and a one and a one, the top three genes there are the ABP1
genes, I'd say, you get used fermented foods. So we have to go strictly with enzymes out of a
model and, and probiotics out of a model for you because fermented foods are not going to be,
yeah, they carry a lot of histamine. So they're really good for a person,
but not everybody can do fermented foods. So before I get a person's 23 and be back,
I say no to fermented foods because fermented foods, if the person has a bunch of defects in this
gene right here, they will absorb a ton of histamine. And then you have to look at another gene
called the HNMT gene. If they have a bunch of defects in those genes, they don't get rid of histamine
out of the tissues. So that is a huge source of chronic inflammation because histamine is essential,
you know, to deal with an antigen. So it's made by your best cells to deal with antigens. And
then it's supposed to have a very short half-life. The HNMT gene makes the DAO in the tissue
to break down the histamine in the tissue to get rid of it. So if they have a lot of HNMT genes,
they don't do that. So they have this chronic ramped up tissue inflammation. And if they have
defects, ABP1 gene, then they absorb a lot of histamine, making the problem even worse. So
but as far as dietary sources of histamine, if they don't have any defects in this ABP1 gene,
even if they have a lot of HNMT gene defects, I tell them to go ahead and they should be consuming
fermented foods. Does that make sense? Absolutely. That's a really great point on histamine
and I know it's becoming a big topic in the, you know, functional medicine world and the genetic
world. I know like DAO can be purchased as an enzyme. It's beginning more difficult to find
bromelene, quesitine, rootins, those are some other nice players to help break that stuff down as well.
Yeah, so what question, like a practitioner might say is, well, if they have defects of that ABP,
one gene, can they just take DAO with their food, with their high histamine foods? And the answer is
yes, they can't. The problem is it's not a real cheap enzyme for the patient. So, you know, costs
wise, it's, it might not be the smartest thing to do. But if you're truly having trouble getting
a person's gut back in order, I'm done that as well. So you're at least breaking down the histamine
in the food. They get the benefits of the other benefits of the fermented food without the ill
effects of the histamine. Yeah, that is a, that's a great point. Always multiple ways to try to address a
problem. The other genes that I put on this slide are the oxalate genes. There's oxalates in
really good foods that you want your patient to eat. But if they have a gene picture that look like
this, this example, that you want to give them a very simple calcium citrate product to help
them bind the oxalates in the gut. So it gets deposited in the toilet and not absorbed into the blood
strabe to cause these stones. Yep, getting stones and arteriosclerosis and some of those, some of those
ways. Right, so how about the BCM? The BC of OGD is how you break down beta carotene. It
utilizes beta carotene. And we have that under the gut profile because vitamin A is essential for
all epithelial tissue. And remember the histology of the gut is its epithelial and origin. So
as far as healing the gut, the gut healing itself, like this person made it, some extra vitamin A.
To help them their gut heal. And then these FUT2 genes are, this is the butyrate picture right here.
So the most important, the most weighted genes in this family of genes in the FUT2 are the top three
of the bottom three of this person's gut defects. They don't produce butyrate very well. They really
need, this is the perfect picture of somebody needs to be on the sudspectrum. Yeah, ongoing.
Yes, absolutely. We see really cool changes with the person on that because they're like,
you know, quick changes too, so it's a good product for that.
Excellent. Okay, so yeah, here we got sudspectrum. I think we did a pretty good job of covering
at least the things in this slide, what we really like about the sudspectrum.
Like we've talked about a few times, it's just got so many great things in it and it brings the
cost down for the patient because there's so many good things in it that the patient is looking for
not only their gut healing, for their cellular energy, you know, for inflammation,
and for, you know, potential anaerobes and things like that. Just another reason we really really
like this guy, and of course, you know, for the people that have the genetic defects.
Absolutely. So this does not have enzymes in it. So that's why you really need to deal with that
as well. And, you know, one of the reasons why we didn't put the enzymes in it because there's
a lot of different choices depending on what you're going to try to do with the person.
Yep, absolutely. So you just kind of, we talked a lot about the HCl enzyme and why we really
like that. It's a very clean source of HCl. It's got the astrozyme in it and it's got some
fungal-based enzymes that are super important because they are the only ones that will stay stable
inside a hydrochloric acid capsule because they have a pH range that can tolerate that.
So that's why there's only a few enzymes that are in the HCl. And then the digest
enzyme, of course, is our biggest broad spectrum, you know, 23 different digestive enzymes,
very, very balanced product. And then, of course, the good enzyme is for the people that are highly
sensitive to gluten cross contamination, you know, soy, casings, things like that. And then the
biomzyme is just that nice little multi-strain highly potent probiotic to come along with. And
like you said, one thing we really like about the products is the dose is you don't have to take a lot.
So, you know, one capsule, a meal, one capsule after a meal, or you're taking your probiotic,
you take it in the evening, you don't need a lot.
Right, yep, great, great sources.
All right, well, anything else you'd like to touch on here tonight?
Oh, I, you know, just, you know, if you're a practitioner that's getting
in deep, get them, get some labs done on the person, change their diet. If you're a practitioner that's,
you know, just starting to get into this, if all you did is give the person,
you give every single patient the HClzyme, I mean, hands down. But then if you have somebody with
your, that wants to deal with, with their got to deal with the deeper level of health,
get them on the sun spectrum and, and HClzyme and maybe digest time. Without, you know, going into
the expense of, of labs with that patient can be, you could see a good percentage of your patients
turn around. Absolutely. You just start simple, especially if you're not working on the really complex
sick people like you're used to, you just, yeah, you start simple and you can see just some amazing
changes in a very, very short period of time just by a couple of supplements addressing some lifestyle
changes and, yeah, it's just amazing how simple it can be sometimes. So, yeah, if any of you
dox want to learn some more, you have a tougher case or you have something, you know, that you'd like
to, you know, get deeper on clinical applications, research, you can email me at Jason at USN Zimes
and you can find Dr. counters on his website and his blog and videos, he's got tons of great
ones out there and then on our website as well, we have a lot of videos, you know, on our products
and things as well and we're just going to keep cranking them out. All right, sounds great.
All right, thanks everybody and we look forward to seeing you next time.